أه أولاً وقبل كل شيء أريد فقط أن أرحب
بالجميع على متن الرحلة أه شكرًا لكم جميعًا
على انضمامكم إلينا في هذه
الرحلة التاريخية أه هذه
أول رحلة طيران تجارية على
الإطلاق من
إسرائيل إلى دولة عربية خليجية أه من
الواضح أننا  يتم الترحيب الآن ،
نحن نطير فوق المملكة العربية السعودية ،
المملكة العربية السعودية ،
لقد كانوا لطفاء للغاية للسماح لنا
بالتحليق فوق مجالهم الجوي وهو ما
لم يفعلوه من قبل
لطائرة تجارية إسرائيلية ،
وهذا مرة أخرى يعد
إنجازًا تاريخيًا آخر  لكني أعتقد أن
كل هذا هو تعبير
عن
ما هو ممكن في الشرق الأوسط
الذي نراه اليوم
على مدار السنوات الماضية ، تحدث الناس
عن كل
الأشياء السيئة التي حدثت في
الشرق الأوسط وكل الصراع و
الفوضى والانقسام
الذي كان موجودًا على مدار العقود الماضية ،
لكنني أعتقد أن هذا يبشر
بأمل جديد بين جميع الناس
بأن
السلام ممكن وأن هناك
فصلًا جديدًا  أن تكون مكتوبة
وأريد فقط أن أعترف بأن هذه كانت
رؤية الرئيس ترامب للشرق الأوسط
منذ البداية ،
كان عليه أن يفعل الكثير من الأشياء غير التقليدية ،
فقد قام بتحريك الكثير من اللوحات
ولكن كما ترى النتائج تتحدث عن
نفسها و  لذلك
أظهر الرئيس ترامب اليوم أنه
يمكن أن يجمع الناس معًا
وقد تطلب الأمر أيضًا قيادة عظيمة
بين أه ولي العهد
محمد بن زايد ورئيس
الوزراء بيبي
نتنياهو وبينما قامت القيادة بعمل رائع
أه هذه القطعة شيء يتم
بحرارة شديدة  رحب به جميع
الأشخاص الذين يريدون أن يجتمعوا معًا
بسرعة كبيرة ، فهناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
يرغبون في إجراء تبادل ثقافي والذين يرغبون في
القيام بأعمال
تجارية ويريدون عيش حياتهم ،
وهذا ما يجعلني متفائلًا جدًا
وفعلته منذ البداية  الشرق الأوسط
هو
أن الناس كانوا في مكان مختلف
عن السياسيين وكانوا في
مكان مختلف
عما قاله جميع الخبراء لك.
كان على المنطقة أن تكون
كذلك ، لذلك آتي إليكم اليوم متفائلًا
جدًا ومتفائلًا بشأن ما هو
ممكن وأشكركم جميعًا على انضمامكم إلينا في
هذه الرحلة التاريخية